so there's so many different ways we
could take this conversation just with
how many different examples are at play
right now um there's the united states
versus other countries and then just
other countries versus each other uh but
what i want to first start with is this
idea of the gray zone um and then
eventually kind of a gray war so first
let's just start with the gray zone what
exactly does that mean
so gray zone conflict is a military
concept that refers to
geopolitical conflicts that are taking
place uh underneath the conventional
threshold of war so
typically
um historians and military experts
define war
as loss of life and physical destruction
and here uh you know we have
seen over time that
war is a spectrum it's not always binary
you know some famous thinkers have said
that war is politics by other means and
so it's interesting because with the
advent of
modern day technologies
governments can actually
engage in political warfare in ways that
are very very impactful and very
effective but in ways that don't always
materialize in
loss of life or physical destruction and
so that's why
you know
one of the things that i did when i was
working on the book was asking myself
what it what do you call
a paradigm when a predominant pervasive
feature of international politics is
gray zone conflict and ultimately that's
why i decided to refer to it as the grey
war
and so when you think about that what is
probably one of the best examples you
could think of of how this actually
plays out in kind of the real world of
international politics
so one of the best examples two examples
that i talk about are um
uh i the the book basically discusses
two fronts to this great war there is
what i call the front end
software layer of the internet and uh
it's the front-end side of the war
uh which is um
the the domain space where russia saudi
arabia iran and china are primarily
involved with that includes the
publication of content it's what you see
on the surface of your screen
that has a lot of players because
software is very cheap and there's a low
barrier to entry and then there's the
back end hardware piece of the war which
is basically where the the stakes are
the highest the two biggest players on
the back end is
uh are the the us and china those are
the only two players that have the
engineering wherewithal to be serious
players in the hardware space and when i
say hardware i'm really referring to the
physical internet infrastructure
that basically
runs the backbone of all of our devices
from semiconductors to
submarine internet cables to satellites
if you control the
physical infrastructure of the internet
you can basically have control over
everything that runs on top of it now
for our country we have a political
system that differentiates
the public sector and the private sector
so our government can't legally just go
around snooping on every company's
intellectual property on everyone's
communications
um and you know when there are excesses
that occur we have a system when they
can be litigated in an open press taken
to an independent judiciary so forth and
so forth in china you have a system
where you don't have that distinction
between public and private so whatever a
chinese company does like huawei for
example
which is a real world example
what huawei does the chinese government
has a back door into and that is why
it's such a big risk because and that is
why the u.s government banned the use of
huawei because uh any
any type of communication or service or
information that runs on top of huawei
the chinese government would be able to
have access to which is a massive cyber
security risk obviously
so when we think of let's take huawei uh
being the example you just described uh
it would make a ton of sense if i'm
sending emails or texting or making
phone calls or some sorts of sensitive
communication
upsetting files you can just kind of go
down the the whole list of all the
things that we really wouldn't want
anyone else to be able to see and if
that is in fact compromised then they
would have access to it and so okay
let's ban that but if we go to what many
people would consider more of an
elementary example and maybe one that
they don't see as much risk and
something like a tick tock what is the
concern around
a platform where you know people
hopefully aren't sending
classified documents or sending you know
private sensitive information and doing
communications in that way it's more
kind of a public platform does that also
fit within the same kind of framework
i think it does and the reason is that
the problem with tick tock really isn't
the data that people are entering
in tik tok it's not the the
um there's very little intelligence
value to
the content that streams on tick tock
where the cyber security risk comes in
with tick tock is
the the data on people's phones that is
not on the tick tock app that the app
collects so
you know i mean you could just imagine
like your address book uh your location
data
uh everything that you're copying and
pasting on your phone which for a lot of
people a lot of people copy and paste
their email and password um all the all
of those data points could potentially
be collected by the tick tock app
and so that's really where it's not so
much about the thing happening in the
app it's more so that if they get the
app onto the device then all of a sudden
they can compromise other areas or other
data points
exactly exactly and and really um
there is uh and obviously once tick tock
has the data the change government can
have the data which is kind of the
thrust of the issue and that's actually
why the indian government banned tick
tock along with
several other hundreds of chinese
applications
so you also have this other framework
that i find fascinating you call it the
usability destructiveness paradox of
modern warfare
describe what this is and kind of how
you look at this as almost like the new
weapons of war
in kind of the modern time
yeah so
um an interesting paradigm so one of the
reasons that um
that we have seen
gray zone conflict take center stage and
international politics is because there
is an inverse relationship between
the practical usability of a weapon
and its degree of physical
destructiveness so to take an extreme
example if if a country only has
high-yield nuclear weapons the only
policy choices it has at its disposal to
engage in
you know commonplace political warfare
is uh either not doing anything or total
annihilation
and that is not very practically usable
on a day-to-day basis so
what uh
what a lot of countries have been doing
instead is uh resorting to much more
usable types of weapons that don't cause
as much physical destruction but that
are more usable like cyber weapons and
so it's interesting because
the less physically destructive a weapon
is the more usable it becomes and that's
why
you know as the internet uh starts to
touch upon
more and more areas of our lives the the
degree the potency of cyber weapons has
gone up uh substantially and that's why
they're becoming so much more usable